قذف صاروخين يستهدف قاعده عسكريه تستضيف
قوات تركيا في نينوى بالعراق
حزمه مساعدات عسكريه امريكيه بقيمه
مليارين ومئتين مليون دولار لاوكرانيا
وبريطانيا تستعد لاضراب عمال ضخم وسط
توقعات بخسائر قاسيه للاقتصاد
[موسيقى]
صباح الخير افادت مصادر امنيه عراقيه
صواريخ استهدفت قاعده ازليكان العسكريه
الواقعه بمحافظه نينا وشمالي العراق والتي
تستضيف قوات تركيا وبحسب المصادر سقط
اثنان من داخل القاعده من دون وقوع خسائر
بشريه
ينضم الينا من اربيل مراسل العربيه احمد
الحمداني اهلا بك احمد ما التفاصيل حول
هذا الهجوم حتى الان
صباح الخير طبعا
ننتظر بيانات حكوميه حول ما اسفر هذا
الهجوم كون ان المصادر اكدت ان صاروخين قد
سقطت داخل معسكر الزليكان الذي تتخذ منه
القوات التركيه
مقرات لها منذ اكثر من ست سبع ست او سبع
سنوات وان سته صواريخ في محيط هذه في هذا
المعسكر بالتالي فان هجوم جديد على غرار
الهجمات القديمه التي تبنتها فصائل
مواليه لايران ومعارضه لتركيا وقد في هذه
الهجمات السابقه وكانت من تنطلق من داخل
الموصل والجهه الشرقيه تحديدا كانت
الهجمات حتى الان دعينا ننتظر الوقت بعض
الوقت حتى نتاكد او تتضح الصوره اكثر في
ماذا كانت نفس الطريقه بمعنى من نفس
الاماكن شرق
الموصل ام من اماكن اخرى او ان من الذي
سيكون
متبني لهذا الهجوم الجديد هل هم انفسهم
همم احرار احرار سنجار الذين الذين هم
طبعا بالاصل هم همم بكك وفصائل مناوي
لايران تعرف سيد الشهداء وما الى ذلك
بالفصائل تمتلك صواريخ كاتيوشا تم تاريخ
صواريخ ايضا همم اخرى همم وتمتلك ما تمتلك
من من اسلحه وطائرات الدرونز
وتتخذ من جبل سنجر مخازن لها وتهاجم تركيا
في تلك المناطق صحيح انا بغداد حتى الان
لم تصدر ببيان الا ان ان تواجد تركي على
تما كان واا
كان مرفوضا بغداديه العراقيا وايضا كرديا
في في اربيل لكن واقع حال معسكر تركي ضمن
40 معسكر لاتراك للاتراك داخل اراضي
العراقيه
من بغداد كما ذكرت حتى الان ولكن ربما
اربيل فقط
الى اقليم كردستان حكم تقليم كردستان فقط
هو الذي اكد الحارس طبعا همم اكد الثمن
الصواريخ واكد الاثنين من الصاروخين الذين
اللذان طبعا سقط داخل لكن لا تعليقات
حكوميه بهذا الموضوع الموضوع صحيح في حدود
اقليم كردستان حدود الجنوبيه او حدود دهوك
الجنوبيه اي في ضمن
لانه محاذي لمناطق الموصل بالتالي فان
بعشيقه بلده بعشيقه جزء منها فيها معسكر
زي اللي كان يتبع الى اداره
اقليم لكن المنطقه
باغلبيه جغرافيا تتبع الى الموصل موصل
واربين مع اليتام بهذا الموضوع فصائل
كثيره متواجده بالقرب من هذا المعسكر
بمعنى اننا نتحدث عن فصائل مواليه لايران
منسقه ومرتبطه معارضه تركيا تنتشر بالقرب
من تلك المناطق وبالتالي المتهم لتلك
المنطقه شكرا لك من اربيل مراسل العربيه
احمد الحمداني
نبقى في العراق حيث قال رئيس الحكومه
العراقيه محمد شيعه السوداني ان ملايين
الدولارات تهرب بشكل يومي الى خارج البلاد
وبفواتير مزوره موضحا اكتشاف الامر بعد ما
تم التزامه الجميع باجراء التحويلات عبر
منصه سويفت الالكترونيه والتي تتيح للبنك
المركزي الامريكي المراقبه في وقت خسيره
العمله المحليه اكثر من 10% من قيمتها ما
ادى الى موجه تظاهرات متفرقه احتجاجا على
تراجع القدره الشرائيه للمواطنين
عربه رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو عن استعداده للتوسط بين روسيا
واوكرانيا حاله طلب البلدان وامريكا ذلك
وفي الوقت او الظروف المناسبه على حد قوله
نتنياهو كشف ايضا ان بلاده تدرس ارسال
مساعدات عسكريه الى اوكرانيا مؤكدا نقل
الولايات المتحده الى اوكرانيا مخزونا من
الذخائر المدفعيه والمخصصه لاسرائيل
الاستراتيجيه في مجلس الامن الوطني
الامريكي
عن تراقب البيت الابيض طرحه ازمه اوكرانيا
وروسيا على الطاوله الصينيه الامريكيه
وذلك خلال زيارتي وزير الخارجيه
الاسبوع المقبل وقد حذرت واشنطن حظرت بكين
مسبقا من تقديم الدعم لروسيا في تجاوز
العقوبات او تقديم المنتجات عسكريه
واشنطن تستعد لارسال المساعدات عسكريه
لاوكرانيا الاسبوع الجاري تبلغ قيمتها
اكثر من مليار دولار ومن المتوقع ان تضم
صواريخ بعيده المدى ومعدات لانظمه الدفاع
الجوي لصواريخ
والاخائر واسلحه مضاده للدبابات وبحسب
مسؤولين امريكيين لوكاله رويترز جزءا من
المساعدات سياتي من صندوق مبادره المساعده
الامنيه الاوكرانيه
لادارهيدن بالحصول على الاسلحه من منشات
التصنيع وليس من مخزونات الاسلحه
الامريكيه
قبل ذلك اعلنت وزاره التجاره الامريكيه
فرض قيود تجاريه جديده على سبعه كيانات
ايرانيه بسبب انتاجها طائرات مسيره
واستخدامها في روسيا في مهاجمه اوكرانيا
وان الشركات والمنظمات الايرانيه وضعت او
وضعت قائمه قائمه للمراقبه او الرقابه على
الصادرات الامريكيه تتضمن كيانات منخلطه
في انشطه تهدد الامن القومي والسياسه
الخارجيه الامريكيه الكيانات الايرانيه
تضم شركه لتصنيع محركات الطائرات والقوه
الجويه التابعه للحرس الثوري الايراني
ومعها منظمه الجهاد للاكتفاء الذاتي
بالاضافه الى شركه
اوجينا فار وشركات بارا فار فارس وشركه
القدس لصناعه الطيران وشاهد لصناعات
الطيران في بقاله ايران ان العقوبات لن
تؤثر على قدره طهران في انتاج الطائرات
المسيره والتي تصنع محليا بشكل كامل
وصف الرئيس الايراني ابراهيم عيسى في
مقابله مع التلفزيون الايراني وصف
الاحتجاجات التي تشهدها ايران منذ مقتل
الشابه مسالميني على يد الشرطه وصفها
بالاضطرابات وقال انها تسببت في اضرار
اقتصاديه واضاف رئيسي ان المظاهرات عباره
عن شغب تسبب في نظره الدولار
اكد وزير الخارجيه الامريكي اند
سيليبلانكين خلال مؤتمر صحفي في القدس
الغربيه اكد ان امريكا واسرائيل ملتزمه
بمنع ايران من الحصول على سلاح النووي
اسرائيل
ومواصله الوقوف جنبا الى جنب مع بلدان
اخرى ضد الكثير من الانشطه الايرانيه
التكنولوجيا الطائرات المسيره لروسيا
لاستخدامها في عمليتها العسكريه باوكرانيا
قالت السيناتور الجمهوريه سنتيالوماس ان
نهج اداره ترامب تجاه ايران كان افضل
لبلادها ولاسرائيل على حد على حد سواء
مشيره الى انه في حال اتيحت الفرصه امام
ايران لضرب اسرائيل ستكون الولايات
المتحده هدفها الاول
كان افضل لامريكا وافضل لاسرائيل اتمنى ان
تعيد ادانته بعيدا النظر في بعض مقارباتها
تجاه ايران لذلك يمكننا حمايته اقرب حليفا
لنا في الشرق الاوسط وكذلك حمايه امريكا
لانه بمجرد ان تتاح لايران الفرصه لالحاق
الادب اسرائيل ستكون امريكا هدفها التالي
هذا هو قلقي
نتابعوا معنا بعد الفاصل
امين عام النيتو يهاجم بكين ويتهمها ببناء
قدرات عسكريه لتاكيد سيطرتها على بحر
الصين الجنوبي
اهلا بكم من جديد تستعدوا بريطانيا
لمواجهه اضخم اضراب العمال منذ اكثر من 10
سنوات حيث يتمتنع اكثر من نصف مليون
بريطاني عن الذهاب الى اعمالهم كما اعلنت
نقابه الخدمات العامه والتجاريه ان حوالي
100 الف موظف في الخدمه المدنيه سيضربون
اليوم وذلك بعد فشل محادثات مع الحكومه
لانهائي نزاعان بشان الاجور والوظائف
وشروط العمل
قال الرئيس التونسيه قيس سعيد خلال زيارته
الى سكنات الحرس بالعوينيه بالعاصمه ان
هناك جمله من الجرائم تم ارتكبها ولابد من
محاسبه من اقترفها مشددا على ان الشعب
يريد المحاسبه
الابحاث ولكن لابد من محاكمتي هؤلاء
هؤلاء الذين
اغرقوهم في هذا المركب وكانت العمليه
مدبره
افضل الانتخابات التشريعيه في تونس الى
انتخاب 154 نائبا من اصل 161 سيشكلون
برلمان تونس الجديد وبعد اعلان هيئه
الانتخابات عن النتائج الاوليه للانتخابات
تضاربت ردود الفعل حولها من بين مؤيد
ورافض
امراه واربعه وخمسون نائبا
و 160 سيشكلون برلمانات تونس الجديد بعد
استكمال الاستحقاق التشريعي الاول منذ
اعلان الاجراءات الاستثنائيه في البلاد
على ان يتم ذلك طبقا للاجراءات القضائيه
والقانونيه
895 الف واثنين ناخذ تونسي توجهه الى
صناديع يوم 29
على طبيعته الانتخابات التشريعيه وما حف
بها من ظروف سياسيه الى ان منظمات المجتمع
المدني المحليه والدوليه القارات بانها
كانت نزيهه
جيده جدا خاصه للانتخابات
لم يتجاوزوا ما بين خمسه وسته في المئه من
الجسم الانتخابي وفورانيه النتائجيه خرجت
قوى المعارضه في ما عدا استثمارا سياسيا
لتطالب الرئيس سعيد بالتنحي او على الاقل
بادخال تعديلات سياسيه كبيره على برنامجه
لا يتاخر الرد من سعيد ليعلينا نهايه
المنظومه القديمه ملوحا بالمحاسبه
تونس تونسيين والتونسي
وليست
فيها من يشاء كما يشاء رؤساء يتحمل هؤلاء
مسؤوليه تخيلتهم العظمى اللي تونس قوس
برلمان 2019
الغنوشي لم يعد بتلك الحسنه التي يحفظ بها
كرئيس برلمان ليس داخليا فقد حزم الامر
ولكن خارجيا
وينتظر هنا عقاد البرلمان الجديد منتصف
شهر مارس اذان المقبل على اقصى تقدير وعلى
راسي اولوياته الملفات الاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه
وبعدما بحث صناديق الاقتراعي باسرارها
وتوضحت ملامح البرلمان الجديد تتوجه
الانظار نحو مالات الازمه المركبه وافاق
حلها مع تمدرس كل طرف بموقفه بما يبقي
الوضع مفتوحا على اكثر من احتمال وليد
عبدالله العربيه
تونس
حذر الامين العام لحلف النيتويين خلال
زيارته اليابان حذر من ان الصين تبني
قواتها العسكريه بشكل كبير وتاكيد وتاكد
قوتها في المنطقه
النوويه دون اي شفافيه انها تحاول تاكيد
سيطرتها على بحر الصين الجنوبي وتهديدات
تايوان تحاول ايضا السيطره على البنيه
التحتيه الحيويه
يواجه كلا من الرئيس الامريكي الحالي جو
بايدن والرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
يواجهها تحقيقات بسبب احتفاضهما بوثائق
سريه في مكتبهما او منازلهما الخاصه
وثائق سريه لا لا ليست سريه ان كانت سريه
او غير ذلك كيف يمكن ان ينتهي الامر بتلك
الوثائق الحساسه في غير محلها وكيف يتم
التخلص منها عند كل صباح يتم اعداد ملخص
يومي استخباراتي لشاغل المكتب البيضاوي
المواد الاكثر سريه وحساسيه عاده ما يتم
اعدادها خارج البيت الابيض داخل الوكالات
الاستخباراتيه المتخصصه
باستخدام طابعات خاصه متصله بنظام البريد
الالكتروني المصنف
يقوم الافراد العاملون هناك بطباعه
المستندات وتجميعها في ملف خاص بمجرد ان
يصبح الملف جاهزا يستلمه الشخص الموكل
اليه ايصاله الى البيت الابيض ثم يتم وضع
الملف في حقيبه مغلقه جيدا فيما يسجل
المسؤولون في المكتب بيانات تلك الوثيقه
المستلمه من استلمها وفي اي وقت غادر
والجهه المرسله اليها الوثيقه بعد
الانتهاء من تلك العمليه واصال الحقيبه من
المفترض ان تتم اعاده تلك الوثيقه الى
مكانها مره اخرى
حيث سيتم تسجيل عودتها وفي معظم الحالات
تحرق تلك المستندات او تتم تلك العمليه
لاحقا
ومع ذلك في بعض الحالات يختار الشخص
المسؤول الاحتفاظ بالوثائق لايام او حتى
اسابيع
عمليه معقده يتم بها نقل الوثائق السريه
وارجاعها ومن ثم التخلص منها الا ان
وثائقي فلتت من قبضه تلك العمليه
الامر الذي اوقع الرئيسيين بيض وترامب في
فخها فخ الوثائق السريه
اخفق برلمان البرو مجددا في التواصل الى
اتفاق لتقريب موعد الانتخابات التي ستسهم
بدورها في وضع حد الاحتجاجات العنيفه
المتواصله منذ اسابيع واسفرت الاحتجاجات
عن مقتل 48 شخصا جراء الاشتباكات بين
الشرطه والمتظاهرين
كشف الادعاء العام في المانيا عن تفاصيل
صادمه لجريمه هزه الشارع شهرها اغسطس
الماضي حيث تواجه فتى المانيا من اصل
عراقي تهمه القتل العمد بعد ان استدرجت
فتاه لها ملابسها
[موسيقى]
قتلت فتاه تشبهها لتلفق خبر وفاتها
جريمه هزت الشارع الالماني في اغسطس
الماضي لكن الادعاء العام
كشفت تفاصيل صادمه 2022
من اصول عراقيه
لكن الصدمه جاءت في اليوم التالي بعد
تحليلات الحمض النووي تبين ان الجثه تعود
لفتاه اخرى واسمها خديجه تشبه كثيرا
الفتاه المفقوده التي عثرت الشرطه عليها
لاحقا
واحتجزتها على ذمه التحقيق
وفق الشرطه فان المتهمه رتبت وفاتها
المزوره وقررت الاختفاء بسبب مشاكل عائليه
من النساء اللواتي يشبهنها عبر تطبيق
انستغرام
توصلت المتهمه ما عدد من الفتيات اللواتي
كانت لديهن ملامح وتشبهوها وقع لاختيار
على فتاه ذات اصول عربيه عمرها 23 عاما
اقنعتها بضروره لقائهما مقابله وعودا
زائفه لم توضح الشرطه تفاصيلها
بعد اللقاء استدرجت المتهمه والصديق اخر
لها الضحيه الى غابه
وطعنها عشرات المرات بهدف تلفيقه خبر
وفاتها
الامطار الغزيره اشتاحت الجزيره الشماليه
نيوزلنديه التي دمرتها الفيضانات مما تسبب
في تعطل الخدمات النقل وغمر الاحياء
والطرق والمنازل بالمياه هذا ولقي اربعه
اشخاص مسرعهم في الفيضانات والانهيارات
الارضيه والتي ضربت مدينه اوكلن منذ
الجمعه
الى العناوين
قصف صاروخيا يستهدف قاعده عسكريه تستضيف
قوات تركيا في نينوى بالعراق
حزمه مساعدات عسكريه امريكيه بقيمه
مليارين ومئتين مليون دولار لاوكرانيا
بريطانيا تستعد لاضراب عمال ضخم وسط
توقعات بخسائر قاسيه للاقتصاد
دمتم بخير